if you consider yourself to be lucky you
tend to be luckier in the future not
because of the voodoo stuff but because
you tend to look differently at the
world you tend to spot opportunity
differently to show you one experiment
they pick people who self-identify as
very lucky or things tend to happen to
me yeah the other and people
self-identify as very unlucky so people
who say bad things tend to happen to me
I'm always in accidents and so on and so
they pick one of each and they say walk
down the street go into a coffee shop
sit down grab a coffee and then we'll
have our conversation what they don't
tell them is that there's hidden cameras
along the street and inside the coffee
shop there's a five pound note so money
right in front of the coffee shop and
inside the coffee shop there's this
extremely successful businessman who
sits next to this one MTC the lucky
person walks down the street sees the
five pound note picks it up goes inside
the shop orders the coffee sits next to
a businessman they have a conversation
they exchange business cards The Unlucky
person walks down the street steps over
the five pound note so it doesn't see it
goes inside the shop orders the coffee
sits next to the businessman ignores the
businessman that's it once you start
looking for the positively unexpected
you start to see it more because it
tends to be hidden everywhere